Star Trek is it an interesting
Crossroads in the franchise
is it dead in the water or is it the
strongest it's ever been welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV the movie
channel
so I get comments all the time on the
channel about how Star Trek is dead that
kurtzman has destroyed it
I actually get dragged into this
occasionally and some people think that
I also hate Alex kurtzman and I don't I
share what I'm told by people that I
know that work in and around Paramount
some parts of the Paramount executive
aren't massively confident about what's
going on with Star Trek and to be honest
that makes sense because as fans we're
quite divided
but is Star Trek at the moment
dead in the water or is it actually the
strongest it's ever been well following
Strange New World season one and now
Picard season 3 which we have both been
pretty popular lower decks continues to
grow in popularity and actually Star
Trek Prodigy even though it was a kid's
show was again pretty well respected you
could argue the Star Trek is doing very
nicely thank you very much now a lot of
people want Picard to have been a
failure a lot of people want new track
just to die they hate it they shout
woken it a lot and they're not always
wrong so where do we really stand with
Star Trek today well I would say that
his popularity
is reasonable it's not as good and it's
not as watched as it was back in the day
when it was a prime time Sci-Fi show on
a network but to be honest it's numbers
compared to other shows generally
speaking aren't bad
now for Paramount it's the jewel in the
crown and for Paramount Plus
it is insanely important
that Strange New World season 2 does
well Picard season three did do well it
actually appeared on the top 10 lists
for all streaming platforms and when it
was airing about episode six or seven
now Star Trek has never appeared on that
list before it always gets pretty high
up on paramounts and even on Prime's top
10 list
but it hasn't actually got the overall
list before so you could argue from that
straight away the Picard season 3 was a
jump forwards more people watched it
it's still true that all of the Star
Trek on Paramount does get good
re-watches Star Trek does still do well
for that even shows like Discovery real
trekkies will watch it again and again
and again but there is a problem
Paramount is financially kinda screwed
and they really desperately need
Paramount plush to succeed
the problem is it isn't it isn't getting
great numbers it's by far the smallest
to the big boys when it comes to the
streaming service and I would actually
argue it desperately needs to merge with
another provider I would say go merge on
Netflix so there are financial reasons
why Star Trek must succeed and I would
actually argue that Star Trek has come a
long way during this period of new Trek
Picard season 3 was an improvement on
the first two seasons and in general
this the tone and the style of the show
has improved vastly from the first two
seasons discovery that were
influenced by the JJ Abram Star Trek way
too much we'll just put it that way it
was dark it was weird and the Klingons
just creeped me out and um it just
generally wasn't well written so it's
improving
but it's still not good enough for me
it's not as good as the original track
it's not as good as Star Trek the Next
Generation Voyager or even D Space Nine
and that's what these shows should be
compared to they shouldn't be compared
to sci-fi that's on our screens today
they should be compared to proper Star
Trek if they don't add up then we
shouldn't be celebrating them
so Star Trek right now is really at a
Crossroads it's improved it's got better
Picard season three actually broke
through that barrier and people actually
watched it people got interested and
excited about Star Trek again so strange
new worlds is vitally important it must
succeed
but will it well I have some concerns
for one I actually really love strange
new worlds but I didn't like the last
couple of episodes they should never
have brought Kirk back it was a massive
mistake I don't know why they did it to
be honest as well I think they really
shot themselves in the foot too early
bringing Kirk is something you do around
season three or four when maybe the
interest is waning a little bit you
don't do it towards the end of the first
season you let the characters that
you've got bed in
if you then need to pull out the big
guns like Kirk later
that's when you do it but they also made
another mistake they badly cast him the
guy that they got playing I couldn't
even bother to Google his name because I
don't like him apparently he was in like
Vampire Diaries or something it was a
bit of a heartthrob don't care
he just isn't Kirk he's just not very
good he looks like he's got a bad back
or something as well he just he holds
himself weird but it's just not right
and to be honest the way he played the
character was just not right and
apparently I'm not the only person that
thought it now Kirk is going to be in
season two a bit more so immediately we
have a risk the last two episodes of the
first season were the weakest of the
season
so how is that going to translate into
season two we've also got a little bit
of an issue with the lower decks strange
new worlds crossover
it's a massive risk having boimler and
Mariner in a live-action version of
strange new worlds if this works
don't get me wrong
could be glorious it could be really
really brilliant but if it doesn't it's
going to be awful
this there is absolutely no way this can
just be an okay episode of Star Trek
it's either got to be
amazing or it's going to be awful
and that's the massive risk that they're
facing at the moment so all I can say is
Jonathan Frakes is directing this
episode he better do a good job because
if he doesn't this is going to be cheesy
and and oh it's going to be painful to
watch it's a strange new worlds must
succeed but there are massive massive
risks and Anson Mount however brilliant
he is might not be enough
so I'm concerned about strange new
worlds but I'm hoping that those
concerns are misguided and it's just a
brilliant series of Star Trek because I
want to see Star Trek succeed I want to
see it get better and better
I've just done a video talking about
actually how Picard season 3 maybe
wasn't as good as I thought please go
back and check it out but it still was
an improvement
I am a Trekkie at heart it's one of my
favorite franchises only second to
Stargate now we then have to remember
that they've also decided to go into
phase two of Star Trek so obviously even
Alex kurtzman knows that they're at a
bit of a Crossroads and then they're
going into the next phase of Star Trek
we're going to be getting a biannual
movie starting with section 31 starring
Michelle yo I'm very excited about that
we're also getting a new live-action
series Starfleet Academy Star Trek 90210
teenagers running around well I can see
absolutely no risks there at all
we really are going into a Do or Die
period for Star Trek it really is Monte
Carlo or bust
and if bad decisions have been made
again like what we saw early on in
Discovery it really could be the death
of Star Trek
but if they get some of them right
we could be going into a golden age of
Star Trek something that we've never
seen before
and I hope for Paramount's sake that
it's the latter but guys please get into
the comments and tell me what you think
do you agree with me that Star Trek has
improved over the last few years that
we're seeing actually some pretty good
episodes of Trek now that maybe there
are still some problems there but that
they are getting fixed slowly or is new
track dead should it never have been
allowed in the first place and is it
just an embarrassment compared to things
like the Next Generation I'd love to
know exactly what you think get into the
comments
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com sidetrack
where most of our videos air first and
you get to see them for small
contribution each month that really
supports the channel without the adverts
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
[Music]